because the doctor doesn't need visuals
to tell a story so this is gonna be my
first ever review of a Big Finish audio
drama about Doctor Who this is not
really my first encounter with Doctor
Who audio because I have dead air which
is a little bit different cuz it's not a
full cast drama it's just David Tennant
doing the whole thing by himself in it
it's a bit more like an audiobook in
that way but I have gotten and now
listen to Shah da and as I said this is
my first time encountering Big Finish
and the way that they handled Doctor Who
audio short version I am quite happy so
if this is spoiler free as I can if I
drop one or two I apologize so there are
a lot of Big Finish audios out there why
did I pick this particular one the
answer is quite simple long before I
knew Doctor Who before I even really
knew Doctor Who was I loved Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy Douglas Adams still
one of my favorite writers ever and
actually in a way he was one of my
initial hooks into classic Doctor Who
after I had gotten into new Doctor Who
and I wanted to go back to the old stuff
the first stuff I watched was stuff that
I knew he had worked on either as the
writer or as the story editor so doesn't
add up as a doctor to me and my mind
already kind of linked in a lot of ways
so this was a story that he wrote back
in the 70s if you don't know the
background on this this was actually
scripted to be filmed with Tom Baker and
they even started shooting it but
production got shut down because they
were trying to get it done at a time
when there was a labor dispute with some
of the unions working at the BBC and the
whole thing just kind of fell apart and
they weren't ever able to go back and
finish it some of the footage did get
used in the five doctors basically just
to try and explain why the fourth doctor
wasn't in the entire us to that and
oddly enough they actually kind of
address
sat in this too but for the most part
this is minimally changed from Douglas
Adams original strip so far as I
understand it I mean there's some
changes to make sure that these stories
go completely through audio and you you
can get by on just the sound but really
the only notable change of the fact that
they turned it into an eighth doctor
story instead of a fourth doctor stories
that means we have Paul McGann as the
doctor which I was very happy to hear
because I have said that I think Paul
McGann is a great doctor but because
I've only been watching the show so far
that means I was stuck with the movie
which he is great in but is not good and
the night of the doctor which is
wonderful but is incredibly short so now
I finally got to spend some time with
Paul McGann's doctor in a good story and
I was quite happy to do so I don't know
where I'm gonna go from here in terms of
Big Finish stuff but knowing that this
is the best way to get an eighth doctor
fix I have a feeling a lot of my early
purchases are probably going to be a
doctor material but in terms of stories
so the doctor goes to Cambridge with
Romana of Romana to Olalla Ward and k9
in tow in order to see a professor just
sort of sensing he needs to see him and
there's something that has to be dealt
with here and then of course craziness
ensues the fact that I know Douglas
Adams's his work means that a lot of
this rank very familiar partly because
Douglas Adams's tends to deal with a lot
of similar tropes and also person
because a character was reused wholesale
from this script the character of
Professor Crowe notice the Cambridge
professor actually appears virtually
unchanged in Douglas Adams his novel
Dirk gently's holistic detective agency
so it was funny it was a character that
I felt like I already knew thankfully
his use and what he does and this is
different enough that I didn't totally
know what was gonna happen but for me
that actually enhanced the experience a
little bit there are a number of other
people thrown in there as well but the
one I want
highlight in terms of the supporting
cast is Shawn bigger staff playing a
character called Chris he basically
function he has the add-on companion for
just this this story in this adventure
and he is wonderful I mean he's just
awesome he's exactly what I love out of
a campaign because there's stucco and he
has no ideas way of his death but
something happens that he doesn't
understand he just kind of goes oh okay
and that's that's the kind of response
to the reaction that I always love from
a wood companion and he's great and he
some people I mean if you're a Harry
Potter fan you know Shawn bigger staff
has Oliver wood from the early Harry
Potter movies and he's great he was so
good in fact that I looked up whether
they actually you ever used him again as
a more ongoing companion for 8dr audio
adventures and sadly they don't how I
wish they did
feels like a waste he was really good
and he's got a great rapport with McGann
in terms of the rest of the supporting
cast all awareness fine John Leeson
comes back as k9 and he's good but I
mean can I can I can get over I think
they got the right dosage of him in this
one so he works just fine but honest of
Cronos is like I said felt familiar felt
almost like slipping into an old sweater
just getting that character again who I
already knew if there's a fall down on
this thing it's a couple of things the
big one though is the villain now the
villain in terms of their scheme it's
kind of generic but it's it comes down
more I think to both the writing and the
performance because one of the downsides
of adapting Douglas Adams a script from
the 1970s is that this feels like a very
70s era doctor whose story particularly
when it comes to the villain which is
just he's a very arch villain he's very
nice and which was kind of the
bog-standard one-off villain from that
era of Doctor Who and that's exactly
what we get here and it's just its
generic and it's kind of campy and it's
over-the-top and it's one of those
things that works better when you're
watching it because you get that
slightly can't beat visuals as well and
it sells it better but when it's an odd
and your brain may or may not be coming
up with campy visuals you may be
envisioning something more grounded or
or whatever and then this hammy
performance just it doesn't work if I'm
I think it's debatable whether it would
have worked at all but in this context
in an audio medium it has a lesser
chance of working for him for me it
didn't really work thankfully his scheme
and what he's doing is interesting
enough that he doesn't totally fall down
but he's not he's certainly not the draw
of this thing I mean the job this thing
is the doctor his interaction and the
end the humor there is a lot of humor in
this as one would expect from anything
Douglas Adams does humor was kind of
really his forte in addition to you know
the sci-fi concepts he was dealing with
so overall I really did enjoy Shauna the
thing that you do need to keep in mind
is that it was written for the 70s now I
think they've adapted it very well for
the eighth doctor in terms of you know
he mind from what I understand of home
began as the eighth doctor which again
is limited but it all seems to fit it
doesn't seem like he's reading line that
were meant for the fourth doctor I don't
know if they goose them or if he's just
that good at making the lines his own so
that works just fine but the overall
feel of the thing is very 70s and if
that era of Doctor Who isn't so much
your thing
yeah maybe a purchase one with a little
caution I mean they embrace the 70s
thing I mean they even used that 70s era
music and in fact they insert the outros
and the intro music at each point which
would have been an episode break had
this actually been filmed as scripted
and gone to air which I thought was kind
of a neat touch but again just
emphasizes how kind of dated the
material is in a way but overall this
was great and I had a very positive
first experience with this being my
first Big Finish Doctor Who story so
shut up
have you ever heard it what do you think
of it if you haven't what Big Finish
stories would you recommend I look into
you know whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe
ring that Bell down there so you get
notifications when I put new stuff up
follow me on Twitter and council of
geese give a listen to the council geeks
podcast my god this outro is getting
lengthy and gotta trim some of this down
but until I do this council is adjourned